we have the college of engineering and
Department of Electrical Engineering
computer science like to welcome you to
this seminar our speaker today is Don
Knuth who is probably best known to you
as a result of his writings his series
of quotes the art of computer
programming and of course as a step in
preparing an infrastructure for
producing such books he took some time
out to do Tet which is widely used here
as is the case of many other leading
universities Don Knuth is a fetcher
Fletcher Jones professor department of
computer science at Stanford University
and he'll be speaking today on some work
entitled experiments with digital
half-tones
first question well I'm certainly
enjoying today very much I've had
wonderful tours of different parts of
the campus here and also glad to see so
many of you here hope you aren't going
to be disappointed if my talk is a light
weight or something I think there's some
anywhere or inconclusive because I'm
this is a it's called experiments with
digital half-tones and I found out this
morning as I went to the Music Lab that
there was a little ambiguity as to
whether or not I was talking about
musical half-tones or our printers
halftone now I buy it right so if so I'm
sorry but you know we didn't want to
resolve the ambiguity ahead of time
because I want to get as big an audience
as possible if you are here from the
music department I'm sorry I hear from
the graphic arts department is going to
be a lot more close to this if I had
said that digital quarter tones maybe
this would have been in a more of music
but I but I'm going to be talking about
some of the things that go into into
making images and and as you see as I
get as I get into it this is work that's
that's in progress in fact what what
happened is that I came up with an idea
last last December that I that that
seemed I would might be promising so I
so I wrote it up submitted for
publication to ACM transactions on
graphics and and I try and I wrote I
wrote a paper that was tried to put into
the format of the ACM transactions on
graphics but I had the card - maybe
transactions on graphics because it was
just submitted for publication well just
last week just the day before I left on
this trip I got the referee reports for
the for the article and they decided yes
they'll accept it for publication but
but I didn't know about six other things
in the literature
that are relevant to the paper so I've
been so I read those over the weekend
and that gave some more ideas and so as
soon as I get back home I have to try
some more things I'll try to explain
what's what does stick that the whole
thing is as as like as I go on now the
main problem that I want to talk about
is trying to do you have a picture and
the picture is given to us in as a large
matrix of values we call you call matrix
a and we try to we try to convert that
into another matrix of the same size B
where B is binary so the original data
is numbers become zero and one
continuously representing the brightness
of the picture at point IJ and the and
we have to convert that to another
binary image either 0 or 1
now depending on who you talk to 0 means
white and 1 means black or the or vice
versa the computer scientist or printer
tends to think of one as where the ink
goes and a person who works with a CRT
or or other graphic system things as one
is where the light goes and so we get
this this reversal and I'm not sure if
I'll be consistent if I say black or
white I but I'll probably think of one
as being black and those of you who
prefer it the other way I'll try not to
say it and some are so often so I'll try
to be also to use a symmetric language
for one thing but maybe I'll need to say
0 is white one spike I don't know maybe
zero is black ones like ah it's it's
somehow the same problem there's this
symmetry about 1/2 and the more ND and
the idea that we we have is that that
well we can't that we want to give the
the impression that that when you see
the binary image you're really seeing a
continuous continuous image and a
halftone the the word halftone so as
opposed to continuous tone means that we
only
it's halfway between I think this white
where the word came out that somehow
halfway between what we wish we have and
what we go we can do because we have
only two two things we can do it either
ink is there or it isn't and when you
win and the problem it rises on computer
terminals where you have two level
displays but but what if it rose most
notably in the printing industry where
they had either to put ink or not to put
ink on parts of the page now the
fascinating problem is that that we
would like to we now have printing
equipment that that can control the dots
of ink with extreme accuracy or it's not
at all uncommon to be able to say if in
every inch every square inch you have a
thousand by a thousand dots and so you
have a million dots in every square inch
that you could either say put ink there
or don't and and this is when you when
you consider that when you when you put
two different dots of ink next to each
other they might blur a little bit in
the surface tension between them and so
on that they'll join together and and
make a loop make them larger blobs and
so on smooth each other out then ink
will will do will do interesting things
but these little the the little
variations are due to the fact that it
still is little dots are too small for
the human eye to see at that now that we
can control the the printers now to us
to things that the human eye can't it
can't perceive our laser printers are
somewhere in between there they're
typically 300 dots in every inch instead
of a thousand and and for this you can
our eyes are good enough to detect the
dragonus between if you have something
that starts out and then moves down one
dot and goes over you can tend to see
that but it is a thousandth uh it's it's
invisible and I suppose it won't be long
before we have laser printers that are
also
at a higher resolution and so that the
these dots we can we can essentially put
dots on the page just and plot as well
as you could put ink in any way so we
have perfect control over how to set
these dots and we also think that we're
pretty smart and we have confessed
computers can compute the matrix B from
the matrix a by by thousands of
conceivable algorithm now the the funny
thing is though at the moment we don't
know any better way to compute the
matrix B then to do something that
people did with my analog devices long
before computers were invented in that
and as we all know we can go now and I
find books of photographs at at the
bookstore and these photographs will
will be done if you look under with a
magnifying glass you'll see that there
are little dots on the page and that the
that you don't read don't really have
gray tones there at all but it's so it's
all it's all composed of either ink or
knotting yet these photographic books
look beautiful and continuous and these
methods that the printers are actually
using are not computer in the best books
in fact it's done by by methods that
were developed completely independently
of computers now somehow it's it seemed
to me that there must be a better way to
do that if we have all the extra
flexibility of controlling every little
spot on a page that we could think of a
better way to do this that we can make
photographs look even but even even more
true when they're printed then then with
the methods used by commercial printers
yet every time mathematicians like me
have gotten into this and tried to try
to find a way to compute the way to put
the ink on it we've come up with
something that doesn't look as good as
the ones that are done by the by the old
methods now that's kind of frustrating
because we should think that with with
mathematics and more powerful computers
and so on we ought to we ought to do
better in fact our efforts as always
look rather tacky by comparison with the
with the others now the other people
have been tuning it up for since 1852
when this process was invented
so they've they played with it a lot and
printers also know how to control the
process but the but the question that I
that I think is pretty interesting is to
try to find a matrix B that that
represents in some sense the best way to
route to to correspond to the to the
original matrix a which is the thing
that that that a picture that we're
trying to perceive which you're like the
Mona Lisa
now I'll mention different models of how
we can decide whether B is a good
approximation to a or not but the the
first one that computer scientists
typically start out with is saying that
we would like if we if we look in the
neighborhood of position IJ and we look
at all of the average values of the
values of B there they would be on the
average something like a of IJ so if a
of IJ is approximately 30% then we would
like about 30% of the of the B's in the
neighborhood of IJ to be 1 and the other
70% to be zero so the average would come
out to the average of the B's in the
neighborhood of IJ should be somehow
like a idea that's one simple definition
of what we might want I want to achieve
and for this the visit a method that's
just that's a it's elegant and simple
which I've used to to show as a starting
point it's it's has different names
minimize average errors some people call
it or error diffusion or more common
name I think I'll use in the next after
this paper but flight and Steinberg came
up with this about 72 I think it was
then they have this this nice little way
of marching through the matrix in
computing the B's from from top to
bottom left to right the way we read the
matrix and the algorithm is I hope you
can see it there we just go through is I
and J going through the matrix from top
to bottom left to right
thanks man and and so that so if we see
something that that's unless and a half
it's tend to be closer to 0 into 1 so we
said B to 0 otherwise you said it to 1
however we're also making an error at
this point so we record the error of a
IJ minus bij that's some number that
says that we wish we had made this error
but we've made it and so now we
distribute here to the parts of the a
array that that we haven't come across
yet and so in the next column over we
add alpha times alpha of the error and
then in the in the next row I plus 1 we
fill positions J J's J minus 1 J and J
plus 1 with other other Corrections of
the error and these extra constants
alpha beta gamma delta of can be chosen
so that we get a fairly nice wick
somehow it looks good afterwards and try
to distribute the arrow to some
neighboring places so that if we were
close say we suppose we went down to 0
but it was it was about 1/2 so we were
making a pretty big error then one of
our neighbors would probably be raised
up above a half and so tend to tend to
do it so that's the that's the method
employed
and apply it to Mona Lisa you get
something like this
this so the method has it has a virtue
of fairly little computation and and it
does it does keep the average in the
neighborhood of a part of the picture of
approximately the same as the original
so I I like this method because of its
simplicity I used it a couple of times
for to make needlepoint patterns before
my life with so on we we have some
chairs at our house where we're still
were actually still doing the
needlepoint but I did this 1977 made the
patterns and where we have one of her
and one of me one of the kids each and I
work and you know capturing the way we
looked in in in a small number of bits
and so I kind of like this method and
then I came to the point where I okay so
now I was faced with another problem
where we where we wanted to create a
font for printing half tones and we said
that we would make a font with a certain
number of levels of grey for example of
the idea was maybe 65 levels from 0 64
we would set aside 8x8 areas of our of
our page and then we somebody would tell
us how how great you wanted it and you
chose one of the 65 characters in this
would up and this would give you a
different different things in that level
so about Ray and we could use this font
for typesetting pictures and we made up
we had some experiments with that and
and we were able to do a reasonably good
job not matching the good photographic
books for sure but we could still
understand what the pictures were
afterwards and and I thought I wrote
this up and then I said well not just
for comparison let me let me compare
this this picture that was produced with
8x8 blocks and there were fairly big
chunks they weren't square we made them
made them round
and so they looked a bit better than we
would but instead of doing it this way
let me compare with with the with with
something else I would look that would
look better so I said okay I'll use the
play Steinberg method and I'll and I'll
produce on my laser printer something
where I was really doing one by one
thoughts but doing but but by this
method which was did the minimize damage
area and I was shocked to find out how
ugly the result looked when I did it
this is a slightly different version of
moley's but it's a similar but the
phenomenon occurred with a laser printer
that it was very blotchy you can see
here there's a big book you know somehow
the the the physics of the of the laser
the previous diagram I showed you was
produced by quite a different method
this is what happens when I've actually
controlled each dot each B of I J was
actually saying does the laser turn on
or turn off at a particular point and
what happened was when he had a lot of
black in a row all of a sudden the laser
cream would go into dark black mode and
there was something and somehow it would
you know there would be I don't know her
if you could if you could see the
original it looked like she had she was
wearing a wig made out of spaghetti and
there are other other funny textures
going on in here and so it really
although this was going to be my example
of of what what what I could do sort of
the best laser printer could do and to
try to try to use that as something so
we could take our approximation which
was done with the with a font to
something which was controlled bit by
bit I didn't have a good example at all
because because the the the font method
was working better so so the question I
natural question I had to do is saying
well suppose I wanted to get a small
version of Mona Lisa this is fairly
small picture here what what should I
actually do what would be the best way
to turn on the bits on the laser printer
so I had to learn something about the Lu
a laser printer works and you know I
find out that with a magnifying glass if
you put down a black pick set one of
these little dots on and it also
the scattering effect that affects some
of the other ones and then and there are
there are weird things that happen like
sometimes if you turn on more of the
dots in a laser printer you get
something that looks look that looks
less that looks less bright and there
are very many patterns that I took don't
totally understand but I certainly
wanted to find something that would that
would be more more acceptable in it
another thing I was worried about was
that I knew of some problems that the
supply Steinberg method had and for
example it couldn't be done in parallel
the calculation is inherently serial the
if you look at the formulas that we that
I gave before the the value of the of a
sub MN the one in the lower right corner
of the picture depends by the only way
you can tell what what whether B of MN
is going to be 0 or 1 that very last one
is by going through the entire process
because it depends on all the other
values there's a business it's possible
that if I change if I change the pixel
in the upper left hand corner it will
affect the pixel in the lower right hand
corner the final value so it's
inherently a serial method and it would
be nicer to have a parallel method to do
the calculation another another thing we
noticed when we did the needlepoint
patterns there they would seem to be a
tendency to have ghosts
that is we noticed that when I was doing
some of the earlier experiments with
with the method that sometimes a
person's hairline would be would be
replicated a little bit a little bit
below you would see a trace of the work
of course where black changes to white a
sort of a history effect a little bit a
little bit after that and a little and
then I realized that there was that this
could something like this could I was
sort of inescapable consider suppose I
apply this floyd steinberg method to a
matrix that starts out and all the AI
J's are equal
but they're all enter all to some small
very small positive value epsilon so
imagine that all the AI J's are equal to
0.01 or something something anyway some
small number
well we go through the first row and we
set everything to 0 because it and then
we then all these errors are moved into
the second row so the second row now
contains 2 Epsilon and the second row we
set those all to 0 and so then that
error will will will be moved down into
the third row and we'll get 3 epsilon
and so on until finally we get to a
value that's a little less than 1/2 and
and then it will start to trigger that
one will go above 1/2 and then the error
will be will who cause next week Onaga
so so all of a sudden will have many
rows of zeros followed by one row that's
that's almost that's that where all
error has accumulated so everybody wants
to be about 1/2 right and so we'll get a
row of alternating my white and black
and then it'll start to improve itself
but anyway that the past history of a
picture can can very much affect what
this out what this algorithm does in
worst case it doesn't happen very often
but it can happen oh oh there's another
competing methods for this bus but
before I show you that I might as well
show you one that's uh that's current
here this is a 26th of May 1987 this is
done by an algorithm similar to fly
Steinberg but but they have a more
complicated way of doing it which tends
to avoid some of the some of those
distressing effects on the other hand I
think this would actually come out to
the solid black on a laser printer and
look darker than it then it should I
don't know for sure if you if you
actually would would we put this out on
on laser right or not now we have but
anyway that there's a there's another
widely used technique for for rock for
doing this and it's a very clever method
that almost the same year it's a ploy
Steinberg method but it has a it has
some kind of a history that led to it
anyway here what we do is we have this
magic matrix here which has the property
that as you go through 0 1 2 3 4 5 the
points of stay about as far apart from
previously mentioned points as possible
and the and if we if we would take a if
we would take a matrix that where we
would like to where we would like to say
have thirty thirteen sixty fourths of
the of the pixels equal to one and the
others equal to zero if we'd like to
divide it would be like to distribute
these 13 far apart in some way so that
they would they wouldn't they wouldn't
be too clumped and therefore we'd have
sort of the high frequency or the
ability to to get edges and things in
the pattern well anyway this is this is
considered to be an optimum pattern for
that and the they have a method saying
that that you repeat this pattern over
and over again in your given matrix so
you imagine that this is tucked in the
upper left-hand corner and then you
repeat this periodically wrapping
wrapping around in rows and columns and
so in every in every up for every I and
J you have I'm on eight and J mod 8
tells you where you are in this matrix
and it has a certain number associated
with it if that number is 20 then you
compare to 20 and 1/2 divided by 64 and
if the if a of IJ is greater than that
then you turn on B of IJ otherwise you
leave it 0 you leave B of I to equal 0
and this this method has the has the
property that if if while you have a
constant value then you get the right
average because if the constant value is
say thirteen sixty fourths then you'll
turn then the thirteen of these are
gonna the
from zero to 12 are going to are going
to be turned on and the the ones the
other ones are not so this is this
method called ordered dither
for historical reasons is it is an
interesting way of proceeding and I can
show you what Mona Lisa looks like in
that one so Mona in that one looks looks
like this so here we take in the picture
and every everywhere we got we added add
one of these this pattern which in some
places will will go to one only if it's
very high other places it will go to one
almost everywhere but but on the average
it will go to one with the with with the
right probability and and this method
has one advantage that it's easy to
calculate in parallel you can you can
calculate bij just by plugging in only
in terms of I and J it doesn't depend on
anything in the environment has a
disadvantage that it produces this this
this binary texture that's very looks
very computer ish it doesn't look at all
organic and I has a sort of a recursive
binary nature to it that there really
reeks of computer science in a way and I
so you cannot if you if you're you know
writing inside you're trying to to give
the feeling of a high tech and that that
something has been done in a in a very
artificial way then then okay this kind
of texture would be doing but if you're
trying to publish a Ansel Adams
photography you wouldn't do this so so
that's what however there is a way to do
much to do rather a lot better with
with or another if if the data were pre
processed and in a way that would that
would bring out the edges and so here's
a so-so to call Chris pinning the edges
is a is a nice way to to improve the
quality of that method and and it's
another nice idea I think that is let's
let's consider the average of of each
pixel value a IJ bar to be 1/9 of the
night of AI of a IJ itself and its eight
neighbors by king moves in a chess board
so we would so we can get this this
number which talks about the environment
of
pixel hij and then certainly the the
values of a bar have the same average as
the belt as a itself so so we can now
form a combination a weighted
combination of a and a bar and we aren't
changing the average of the total now if
we but we want here to emphasize the
difference from the average so we want
something that that's that's different
from its neighbor to be a little whiter
if it's whiter than its average or a
little black of is blacker than the
average so if we compute a weighted
average in which we which we wait
negatively with opposite signs the the
the a bar and a then we're emphasizing
the difference from the average and so
this will just gives us a better this
gives us something where they wear edge
effects are are brought out and this
formula simplifies in a neat way if you
take alpha equals 0.9 then all the
fractions cancel out and you get a very
simple formula here where you take a
prime the the sort of enhanced value to
be nine times the previous value minus
the sum of eight neighbors and this is
one of many examples of the formula
above you might not want to be such an
extreme thing
this is one way to do it and it's the
one that I use here so I show you or
together when we've enhanced the
contrast see that so now it's its fact
it's almost incredible that I'm doing
this with just single pixels because you
can see the river in the background now
and you can see details other fingers of
somewhat in the and the well wisps of
hair even to a certain extent and her
small might have gotten a little bit
broader there maybe she developed a
mustache that was part of the sometimes
you might might also bring out noise in
your in your data if you if you enhance
it power or sharpen edges too much but
anyway that this is a possibility and so
you can also apply this to avoid
Steinberg methods so and you see what
happens then in the two cases here with
if this if I you if you take the data
and first and for end first do this
transformation then apply the boy
Steinberg algorithm you get surprising
amount of detail even though you have to
deal with zeros and ones now these
pictures you have to realize that well I
gotta talk more about it later but the
the are I does funny things as well as
laser printers and and printing ink all
are combining to do things when we do
with visual images and and these things
are still imperfectly understood now
here we get to see another another thing
that tends to happen in the boy
Steinberg method all you can't see it
too well but there here it seems like
her the part in her hair it's somewhat
straight the and we end I tends to you
tend to get patterns that look a little
bit like mazes where you have channels
developing in the method on the other
hand I want to emphasize that this this
this this
contrast enhancement this edge enhance
with transformation that we made did not
change the average value of the around
IJ we still have approximately the same
average value as before because we all
we did was was was changing by a
multiple of the average and so we
haven't changed the ever okay now I have
my dear that I thought would would would
work better than both methods it was
something that was like Floyd Steinberg
that would that would do very little to
the error but it would but it was also
like the order did learn that it could
do it in Pelham
I should mention another thing about the
order the order dealer method and that
is that at every at every step we're
making a we're making a comparison where
we could actually make a rather large
contribution to the error we could be
throwing away typically about one-third
of a unit of brightness in either
direction on the average show you say
maybe you'll throw away a third I mean
you can be throwing away even more but
on the average it's something like that
fourth is something on the average you
say this will cancel out sometimes you
make an error in the positive direction
sometimes a negative direction but in
the worst case you could make the error
always the same way and get a completely
distorted view there's no error
correction at all in the ordered it
order method while in the fly Steinberg
method they are very careful whenever
you make an error the error is
distributed to some neighboring place
and and taken into into the picture so
well I had I had the idea that will do
something else and and in the following
way again I use that 8x8 matrix or some
some kind of repeating pattern of
numbers some magic numbers in this case
if you follow the numbers you'll see
that they that they actually don't stay
apart from each other the way they did
before 0 1 & 2 3 4 5 and if I look at
the first now
we say all numbers less than 20 they'll
tend to form two clusters to glob see I
have another picture that shows it it's
really a space-filling pattern with a
zero that some of the there will be one
glob around here and one ones all around
here but you wrap that around then you
get this other matrix and I and I break
the I break the entire picture into into
64 classes of little pixels and all of
those that are for example class zero
would consist of this one and the ones
that are 8 - it's right and 8 below and
so on no multiples of 8 in any direction
apart and consider those two ought to be
all pixels of class 0 and then class 1
is here in class 2 and class 3 and now I
have my entire picture divided into 64
classes of things and now that's the
pattern that I apply a following out the
following error correction algorithm to
it I start out so for every for every
class number K is running through class
numbers and I look at all IJ of that
class like first of all everything of
class zero and then everything of class
1 and so on now I do something similar
to Floyd Steinberg but all in but for
all the things of a class in parallel if
it's less than 1/2 I set to 0 otherwise
to 1 and then I calculate the error and
I distribute the error to the neighbors
of of pixel IJ whose class numbers are
greater than K in other words either the
neighbors that I haven't computed yet so
now sometimes the area is going to be
going up sometimes down sometimes the
left them times the right all the way
around I'm distributing it to 8
neighbors of 0 and then 8 neighbors of 1
and when I get to two I'll distribute to
7 neighbors of 2 that I haven't dug that
I haven't yet seen and so on so that
when I get to binding I'll get up to
number 63 and there won't be any
neighbors for him to distribute anything
to because you know he's the last one so
he's going to have to eat that
there and and live with it but everybody
else so no 62 is also in this situation
nobody nope nobody next to him is a
larger number but up to that time for
example 46 when I'm processing 46 I will
already have processed 38 28 14 and 22
but I can still distribute the error of
46 to 4 neighbors who are yet to come
and so on up so then I won't be losing
very much of my pixel mass in this in
this thing it'll it'll only dis escape
that the at these points that haven't
have no low class neighbors now we call
the points with no localized neighbors
Barrens and there and so you define a
barren position is one in which all the
numbers to the rekt around it are far
lower class and this what this matrix
has to has to Berens okay now I didn't
say how I'm going to distribute the
error to the neighbors and that's up and
I tent out so I can wait that by a
certain by a certain amount I and I and
then I so I and I can I can and I can do
this computation once and for all at the
beginning this particular computation of
the weight of class IJ is it doesn't
have doesn't depend on the matrix size
so it's not very expensive considering I
only doing it once and then I just I
just continue the total weight in this
particular case I've set it up so that I
will wait and an orthogonal neighbor
with the weight of two in a diagonal
neighbor with a weight of one so like
for example the first case if I'm
distributing from zero if I distribute
the error among the eighth neighbors
then my controversy 1 2 3 4 and then 6 8
10 12 so I give to twelfths of the error
to each of these orthogonal neighbors
and 1/12 of the air to the teach of the
other guys
and similarly if I have fewer than 8
neighbors I have a certain way of
weighting the error no this is the first
line I tried and it was reasonably good
so I didn't move any other weighting
schemes and the total amount of
arithmetic that you're doing here is the
same as in Floyd Steinberg that is the
number of neighbors that you have to
distribute to it goes down from 8 to 0
and on the average it's 4 which is the
same number of multiplications that we
were doing for the Floyd Steinberg
method so the so the amount of
arithmetic is the same but the but it's
parallel so it can all be done by a chip
suitably you know go over to the lab and
say make me a chip that does this does
this kind of arithmetic on and well so
this was kind of fascinating just as a
parallel algorithm it's an interesting
process because if you have to imagine
these things do you think these tiles
are next to each other and it and the
one of the interesting properties of
this pattern is that the the last K are
the same as the first K what I mean is
if suppose that I have the if I look at
the pattern of coloring the black the
the first 13 all numbers 0 through 12
and I compare that to the problem of to
the pattern I get by coloring black all
but the last 13 that would be orders it
up to 50 0 through 50 and then I'd have
51 to 63 left over the 51 to 63 will
form a white spot and those white spots
are the same as the black spot except
shifted by four there's in other words
the the pattern as you get of white on
black is is complementary to the pattern
of black on white except for a slight
shift so the the neighbors on the way
the six so if you looked at the 62 for
example the guy next to him there would
be 56 and then
another one over from 59 and that that's
a mirror image of one three four seven
on the reflection so there's some
interesting numerical thing but if you
watch this algorithm as it works you
start out with values at zero and then
the value start going around some of the
error from zero starts moving to the
right some of its start goes up diagonal
and so on and some of the error from
zero is going to wind up at sixty two
sixty two over here some of it will get
all the way over I think by an ascending
ascending path never going down we'll be
able to get down to one of these guys
down here and it can take a long path
going up and down it in some somewhat
interesting ways so so the act so a
little number of arithmetic operations
isn't large the way in which these final
values propagate is somewhat interesting
not exactly mind-boggling but
interesting to imagine this kind of
process in parallel where where things
are going
the arrows are going around and around
but still not interfering with each
other in something okay let's see you
want to see what the picture looks like
though and and so here here are the two
examples and what happens is you see
that the fact that it's a 64 is
repeating with with order 64 makes it
very visible the place where the errors
are occurring does form a regular
irregular pattern however I wasn't
now they by the way this is a smudge on
this um it is white dot here if not it's
not real it just happened as I was doing
making this ax with a slide and this one
right again is the same with the data
that smoke then when sharpen but but
anyway it makes this regular pattern
however I knew that would happen in fact
I wanted to choose a pattern in which
this in which I would get something like
that
of other experiments I had made about
the way our eye works when whinnies well
if you actually look at the beautiful
book of Ansel Adams photographs under a
magnifying glass you look at you'll see
that it has this kind of a pattern and
that's the way they do it with the ink
and and the pattern in a newspaper
photograph and so on and and it turns
out for one thing that if we make the
dots
cle-cle rectangular rectangular left and
right instead of at a 45 degree angle of
the that pattern tends to be much more
noticeable to our eyes there is
something definitely present in their
little children can't draw diagonal
lines until there there are several
months older than when they can draw
horizontal and vertical lines and
there's something about visual
perception that we can notice deviations
from vertical horizontal more in a
printed page than we can when things are
diagonal so uh and I also knew that
regularity was something that would tend
to be modulated out by our eyes
I didn't experiment once which was work
which came out exactly the opposite of
what I had expected I started out with a
I was going to try to see how red and
blue make purple and I took a red magic
marker and a blue magic marker and I and
I drew dots and I started out with a
checkerboard so that blue and red were
alternating and then I added to every
position in the in the picture I added a
random a random change so with
probability P I would change from red to
blue or blue to red and I start out with
P equals zero so I had a perfect
checkerboard and then I would increase P
to point where I was when I'm P was
one-half I was changing with probability
one-half so it's getting purely random
combinations of red and blue dots then I
went to P equals one where again it was
a checkerboard except reversed and my
original idea was that when I when I
have these checker boards I would look
at these red and blue dots and I would
say oh that's a checkerboard I can see
that this is a checkerboard it doesn't
look like purple but when I saw that
when I was
random thing my original preconceived
idea was this random my I would learn
together the random the random things in
and I would see purple what actually
happened was where I had the
checkerboard
I saw purple I couldn't believe that
that was red ink in blue ink but when I
got to the random parts I saw islands of
red surrounded by rivers of glue and in
namely my I very much fused things that
had this had this repeating texture that
had no nothing i catching about it so i
eyes are very quick to pick out shapes
when there are shapes there but when
there isn't the shape there like a
repeating pattern we seem to go by so I
wasn't I wasn't mining you know in fact
this I figured that when when I would
reproduce this on a on a laser printer
on this act this dot would actually
would actually be a help and a win it
would make a nice looking picture
afterward this is not done on a laser
printer this was done very large on a
photo typesetter and then reduced down
as a CRT she okay well this is a
different texture there's you know the
order dealer has one texture the floyd
Sandberg guys another texture this one
has another texture and that's the least
one thing it can be said for the messy
now in fact when I when I applied it to
a laser trainer well here you can look
at you can look at all three again just
work just to see what it looks like
deploy Steinberg at the top three they
all if you go back far enough they all
they actually all have the same average
brightness at the different points and
so it except for the distortions caused
by by making is fly they all I put them
all up in my office and went back about
20 feet and they all looked about the
same except I could see more these were
sharper at the because of the enhanced
contrast on the right well when I
actually came to making on a laser
printer this dis method this uh this
method which I call dot diffusion is
that what my far the winners so those of
you who are more interested in seeing
half tones out of a laser printer I can
show you the hard copy so that you can
see what
what Mona Lisa looks like on this one
and as far as I know right now I don't
know of a better way to produce Mona
Lisa on a laser printer on it on a kind
of a machine that apple laserwriter or
okay or imaging like our HP laser from
laserwriter all I use the same engine
and so this saw actually made a rather
attractive thing the way I did this is a
little bit fun we I don't have control
of the software where I can turn on
every bit of the laser printer and if I
send it one bit at a time on a font that
would just be very small this would come
in too slow for the software and and I
would get all kinds of streaks on the
page and so instead I had to make this
as a font of 64 characters where each
character covers a small part of Mona
Lisa
and so this was so this picture is
actually typeset as a combination of
these six before character and once
you've got something like that then you
can then you can play games like this
and now in this one I took each of those
64 characters repeated four times so you
have sort of 0-0 you know each each
column is repeated twice each row is
repeated twice but you don't see the the
joints between because two matches
perfectly two three and so so although
it goes 0 0 1 1 2 2 3 3 you actually see
0 and then you see 0 1 as a go and then
you see 1 2 is a Glock because there's
you know there's no boundary between 1 &
2 visible so this is something that
Leonardo I'm sure was excited
I tried it on another I tried it on
another image and this one I generated
completely by computer and this points
out the Achilles heel of these methods
in fact so here I just generated a spear
and some background that was gradually
getting darker and this with the Floyd
steinberg method there tends to be a
problem when it like when it goes
through 1/2 here's the area where of 1/2
of where it tends to there tends to be a
band around there where it where it
drops where it drops out and then I was
also very strikes that have that
occurred these artifacts of texture that
seemed to be unfortunately because of
number theory that that they that they
happen because when we were playing this
this method but you notice the enhanced
contrast has the has an interest in
creature how it puts a white stripe
outside the sphere as well as a black
stripe indicate the order givers looks
like this and the and the and the my
doctor fusion method looks like this now
here's where I had a problem that I
wasn't I didn't anticipate so as far as
I was concerned my method was was a
winner for laser printers and I had high
hopes that it would work also when I
increased the resolution for a photo
type center but now on this one
something else is going on so I got to I
got right average values but now but
unfortunately when you step back and
reduce this down then there's some false
contour introduced here where I'm
changing where the picture is actually
just changing gradually getting a little
grayer but the the pattern of black and
white that I choose is not changing
gradually the pattern I'm choosing is
since it's done by this error these
errors are propagating in slightly
different ways I get the same average
number of
guys but they're occurring in a
different different configuration and
this is tending to make to make a little
band in there that's probably going to
be going to be all too visible well
there shouldn't be any band at all
because nothing is going on in that part
of the picture so why I need something
else in order to before I can claim that
this was going to be a the referees in
my paper pointed out to point to two
recent pieces of work and I want to tell
you about those because I want to try to
go and try to stuff as soon as I get
back home and one and so people have
made to two important of know nuttin
other nice ideas I didn't know about
until just last week and worthy of
further exploitation first of all
somebody noticed that this constant 1/2
here isn't important that is I could try
to fly Steinberg method but instead of
one half suppose I've made it 3/4 the
first that seems ridiculous I mean you
have to you know half the time you have
to go to zero on the other and the other
half of time you have to go to one but
suppose suppose this was really 3/4 well
what's happening is that ok you you you
very often set to thing to zero at this
point
but you're making a bigger error so this
error is immediately being spread to the
next thing and it'll bias your decision
and become and and we know that this
method isn't uh is distributing the
errors and so it's still going to come
up with the same average so no matter
what this this the threshold is in here
I'm getting I'm getting a method that
diffuses the error and and comes up with
with the average properties so these two
men in the physics department in Germany
who observed this they decided that they
would use they would combine this with
the method of order dither and they
would choose a different threshold at
every I and J and this this this I and J
threshold would would form some other
pattern that would tend to
to knock out the the improper texture
that sometimes is supplied by by this
boy Steinberg method and and they and in
their experiments they got the best
results when they were choosing the
extra the extra thresholds to form a
pattern something like dots of not not
according to order dither which kept the
dots apart but according to the method
where the clusters uh there are some
parts of it that are arranged like in a
45-degree grid where those dots would be
the first were the ones that have the
highest threshold and then this been
then the other part saw the the white
dots of the complement of the black dots
would be the one to have a lower
threshold but then this would tend to
that then the threshold they were
varying it not between zero and one but
between I think it was two tenths and
eight tenths at these points and they
were getting a an error diffusion method
that that was three of the much more
free of these false contour that was one
one neat idea that I found in literature
the other one was actually somewhat
older and developed in at Xerox in the
late 70s called the Aries method and and
and here what they did was something
like the ordered dither
approach except that they would take a
they would take a six a an 8x8 region of
the of the picture and they would apply
the they would apply the order dinner
method but they would change the
threshold in in that picture to be just
right so that the that the total number
of blacks in that picture would be would
be what you wanted so let me explain
what this is a little bit you got it you
got an area say 64 pixels and you end up
and you you add together all the a
values in those 64 areas and and it says
that it would be nice if I could turn on
thirteen of those 64 pixels okay so now
which 13 should I choose and what they
say is take the take
neither matrix and and so a IJ plus dij
and look at those 64 values take the 13
highest values and make those 1 and and
now this has the property that
well now you can you can choose a dinner
matrix so that these values will look
with groupie group themselves nicely for
for printing ink and so they've got
rather good results with that alright
now what I hope to to find when I get
back to Stanford next week is that I can
actually use both of these methods and
that is I can or both of these ideas
somehow that I well know the second idea
is to is to computationally expensive I
would like to try to use the first idea
changing the threshold combine that with
my method and then see if that doesn't
produce results that are as good as or
better as the as this Ares method who
knows for laser printers like this right
solution might not be the one that's
going to be best for higher resolution
printing and the only way to really
judge this will be to to have some
method that that doesn't just compare
the average values of the BI J's to the
average of the AI J's but to have them
to have something that compares the the
perception as seen by a human being to
of the AI J's to the perception as seen
by a human being of the BI J's and
that's not simply an average in fact
it's not only is it's not only due to
the filly to the things that are the
properties of our eye the way our eye
works and perceives pattern but it's
also due to the properties of the
printing press and the way ink changes
one of the big problems with the order
dither method and ploy Steinberg method
is if you have a picture that's entirely
1/2 all the AI J's are 1/2 these will
give you a checkerboard a perfect black
white black white now this is the
absolute worst thing to put on a
printing press
you can't put dots of ink at the points
of a checkerboard and not dots of ink
there that it just all blurs together it
makes blotches you have to have larger
dots than that because these these
little pixels are terribly small and
prints so it so we need a combination of
a model of what the printing is going to
do what our eyes are going to do and
then try to to see what's going to come
out to be a good a good image after all
of that now our eyes are very good at
picking up differences between between
areas not so good so it's so our eyes
aren't so well tuned to two absolute
absolute darkness we don't know the
difference between 1/3 and 1/4 when
they're in the middle of a picture but
when you put a 1/3 next to 1/4 we see an
edge between this is the this is a I
have a interesting I just stumbled on an
interesting demonstration of this when I
was playing around with my fonts for
half-tones I decided what if I what if I
had a front where I would have 65
characters for 65 levels of brightness
but I would make each of these
characters equally black so there would
be no difference between the black one
and the white one but the only
difference I decided I was going to
consider that I had 60 I had I had the
needles on a dial and and if the needle
is flat this means it's a the a value is
0 if the needle is straight up it's a
value is 1 and and and it's a need you
know a value is one third the needle
goes up one third of the way so you can
imagine that you have a lot of electric
electric ax what is it photoelectric
cells or something I wouldn't touch the
needles and you shine a picture on there
and you see the needles turn can you see
what the picture is well in fact of
course you know you know what this
picture was you've already seen it but
how about this one can you guess what
this picture is see now now every pixel
in this picture has exactly the same the
same black white density there's no
there's nothing darker but any other but
the fact that we can see the difference
between between
between when the needles move that's
where what we're picking up for the
texture and so uh so I guess I thought
in my talk on a patriotic notes doing it
is I have one more example playing find
it yeah where instead of using dials I I
just took horizontal vertical lines and
and I moved to the left or to the right
and up at the same time so here I have
two crosshairs and then and as and and
this is four zero and this is four one
and everything in between is shown here
so amazingly easy to perceive although
there's no difference in in brightness
because of the way our eye focuses on
differences so so I guess the summary of
the the talk is that that we start out
we still have a fascinating problem I
think is find out what pattern of bees
will actually be the best for printing
is it is it is it really going to be
true that nobody can do better than the
then the method the analog methods that
were discovered use before years before
computers come along or can we find
patterns that will actually make make
Ansel Adams look even better
I mean look like the real the real print
instead of the way the way they look in
books our book is going to be able to be
improved even more if we come up with
the right the right of patterns okay
that's my talk question
welcome global averages fight the local
African hire whoa what happened to to
try to kneecap Holmes by first using
randomization the white the white black
Asian error correction my official I
didn't see you didn't say wreck you said
randomization then you said use
high-intensity so though it in fact yeah
this was in fact the idea that I that I
had written in and and got almost ready
to test and then I decided that this dr.
fusion method was going to be better so
I so I threw it in the wastebasket maybe
I should try it again
but I I went through the whole matrix
and I tried to find first of all the the
pixel that was whose whose decision was
was most obvious I mean like you know
the a that's closest to zero it to one
so I kept a big priority queue of all
the pixels and and there were millions
of them of course so I only worked on a
band so I say you know look look at the
say the top 16 rows or something by 350
or whatever I had who still was a very
small small segmented picture but I said
now put those all into a wait the rate
goes all by how how controversial the
decision is there and and then choose
that and you know choose the one that's
that's the least controversial and then
propagate the error to its neighbors and
recalculate the and the same thing again
and keep on going until until I get to
the end okay so so that method was one
that I had planned it to and I had
actually implemented the data structures
and everything and I never did test it
but now I suspect that that's not going
to that's that's going to suffer from
the same banding problem that I showed
you on this sphere
and I looked and won one way to see that
is is if you have any any method that's
going in that well you probably have
something that's going gradually uh from
light gray dark gray what hat we have to
see something that changes very
gradually now if there's any interaction
between these will see a artificial
contour in between and and and one of
the ways to imagine this is suppose that
I'm calculating something where the
where the gray level is is very close to
one half but I mean this is almost too
dramatic but suppose it's opposing the
gray tile is very close to what happened
in the left half of the picture I'm
computing it so that it's so close to
one happened it really comes out to be a
checkerboard like white and on the other
half of the picture it's also close to
one half but on the other side but
somehow I got a little bit more than one
half so Mike so my picture my
checkerboard isn't black white it's
white black so now I have these two
parts and both of them are locally
one-half but there's got to be a place
in there where they meet each other and
it's going to be a big strike and that's
going to appear and so so some method
that avoids any such stripes like that
is absolutely essential to to to avoid
artificial contours that's why I like
the Aries the Aries method seems to be
quite free of that and I should I
suspect that that might be the best we
can do at the moment but I still want to
do some more trial when I'm talking
that's when I say best I mean on a on a
really high high resolution printer yeah
no yes
how important is it
oh all right yeah that's right y'all
know that's another thing that would be
worth is keeping track of all year
that's a this is a the kind of mistake a
mathematician tends to make and and we
you know we we are we have to in
computer science we have to try first
for a clean model but but we have to
realize that the mathematically clean
doesn't necessarily mean best in the
real world and so we have to be willing
to reject that and take something that
something out we try to find the
cleanest one that actually that actually
works but we but we don't stop searching
just because none of the clean ones work
but we should stop so with our
weaknesses that we sometimes stop
searching the when there is a clean one
because we are tolerant enough of the on
one unclean well where was it our the so
you're absolutely right you could we
could for example say that if we have a
small error we won't distribute it at
all or we could say that we only
distributed a certain percentage of the
air or we could you know but some
something probably the air could could
go a little ways now this method that
they use for my pick the picture of me
that I showed you there might be a good
good example of that they they they keep
two matrices they keep the original AI J
and the and the one subject to error
modification so the the so the air so
the errors that they compute are based
on the difference between original a and
computed B well in Feinberg method the
errors are modified a versus computed V
so that the error there is I mean you
see what I mean the employs I'm or
better we update the a makes as we go
along so we're dealing with different
aids but in the in its other method the
a matrix stays the same but it's a
but the the errors are still I still
kept track of the original a versus the
computed B so it's a it takes more
memory but it take but it might might
remove some of this effect of being too
you know too anxious to to save every
little twiddle of air the the history of
computer science is full of examples
where somebody has optimized by one
criterion and their other criteria have
have have gone by the wayside order
dither is one example of this where
we're by one by one criterion the matrix
that I showed you for order did the 0 to
63 was the optimum one but when you try
to apply that to high resolution
printing it turns out to be very bad
because the 50% tone would come out to a
checkerboard which would look back which
would look terrible in a printing press
the same same thing if I try to use the
ordered dinner matrix for my diffusion
method there I would have as many bairns
as possible there would be you know I'd
be eating error in all of hollien way on
the other hand if I take my criterion as
to try to minimize the total amount of
of escaped error then I might be losing
on some other visual grounds and and the
the extra stripe that occurred in the
background of the sphere was an example
of that yes
yeah I I ought to have that for
comparison but they but the I don't
control a pretty you know words like
okay I tried to get I try to go through
the graphic arts department to get to
get some some things like this and and
found out that it was just the anomaly
the printers are weren't able weren't
able to make two things that would be
under the same under the same
assumptions when one of the assumptions
was old and the other was new okay
because they understood the old but they
wouldn't be able to adapt to the new so
they would tune tune them up so that
they would come out the same where they
would do with play games because because
they the fact is that they also have a
lot of dials on the printing presses
that adjust the ink and so on and one of
the worst experience three these three
methods so no Brand X banned why and my
method on the on the spirit and well we
can see it actually because this is
already reduced on a Xerox a lot of the
lot of the thing goes up goes away but
the the fact is they when you when you
when you've tried to make a what kind of
print is this a PMT print and you with a
reduce with a reducing machine and try
to reduce this by a factor of ten you
still have a control on the exposure as
to how long you keep on the light
whether as you're making these prints
and so the operate so I said I'd like to
compare these these three methods to
Brand X brand Y and this one and and no
matter what they would do these would
turn out to be much darker than this
okay so my idea was to make this one
look good and these other ones would
look way too dark see but but the idea
was to make two other you know the best
they would get two out of three anyway
or they would say can
can I do this one with a different
exposure and so then I tried to imagine
what would happen after I took such a
photograph and send it to a CMS printer
and that they would reproduce it in the
journal and so on what and we would get
something it would be impossible to
evaluate so I I have no way of really
evaluating these things well except byte
by byte not you know I can't miss Roxy
copy I'm making now has already been
quite distorted because of the Sirah
grafite but i can show you a hard copy
and laser printer output and that's and
mass in which the subjective judgement
is is finally made that I did like this
method in in 1k the main point here I
want to say is it's a still a problem
and and some more ideas are clearly
possible this is very much in its
infancy
even though there's already a literature
of about a hundred papers on the